let's talk about how to stop being so
darn tired when you wake up in the
morning I used to be so tired for years
I'm talking probably about 15 years of
fatigue in the morning I had no idea
what it was it was terrible it felt like
I had a helmet over my head all the time
like brain fog and it took me until
probably 11 o'clock in the morning
before I can actually wake up so
I guess you would say I'm an expert in
fatigue okay so if you apply what I'm
about to tell you you can easily get rid
of this fatigue and wake up feeling
refreshed and rested the majority of
your fatigue in the morning is really
coming from your diet okay but there's
other things but the diet is the most
important thing
what you ate yesterday is going to
affect you today especially if it's in
the area of too many carbohydrates and
starches and sugars
why is that because when you're doing
that you're running on glucose and your
brain is very susceptible to developing
something called insulin resistance so
what does that actually mean for the
brain it means that
you don't have enough insulin in the
brain to drive the glucose into the
neuron cells so basically you're kind of
startling off your brain cells of fuel
and that does not make your brain feel
good it makes your brain feel tired and
brain foggy you're not you're going to
lack the concentration
now
for me
I would say maybe
late 20s maybe I might have been like
yeah late 20s maybe 28 29 when I
stumbled on
changing my breakfast from a carb
breakfast which I did for years
to a protein breakfast it was like a
switch it was like this helmet lifted
off
and I got really interested in why that
was and I started doing deep dives into
What's called the ketogenic diet but for
me it was very quick but the point is I
mean if you go to the IHOP or or a
restaurant where you have breakfast
foods it's orange juice it's cereal it's
pancakes it's muffins
carbs it's sugar so I know a lot of
people are waking up really really
grouchy and really really tired so it's
not just fatigue it's your mood okay now
are there other symptoms that kind of
prove this point yes if you're waking up
feeling hungry
if you're waking up craving anything if
you're waking up feeling grouchy if you
have any fog in your mind when you wake
up then your blood sugars are off the
worst thing you can do is to add more
carbs to raise your blood sugars to
treat this low blood sugar situation why
because you just you make yourself feel
a little better but then it's going to
get worse because the more carbs you do
the more sugar you do your body is going
to start protecting the cells from that
even more and resisting it more and more
and more it's just a it's a never-ending
cycle a better thing to do is just to
skip the breakfast all together now if
you cut down your carbs throughout the
day
you will find the next day and maybe it
might take two days you'll find you're
not going to be hungry in the morning
your Cravings are going to start going
away why because you're restricting your
body of carbs and sugar and your body
then will start burning fat your own fat
as well as the fat in your diet and if
given the choice your brain loves to
burn ketones okay and that's the
byproduct of fat if you wake up with a
headache if you wake up feeling kind of
bloated
it could be that you went out to dinner
the day before or went out to a
restaurant the day before what you ate
the day before has a huge impact on how
you're going to feel today now
personally my wife and I would in the
past long time ago would go to Taiwanese
restaurants Chinese restaurants we love
that okay and we ate a lot of
rice and we had a lot of carbs and we
had a lot of MSG which is a flavor
enhancer and at the time I didn't even
connect the dots but I would always wake
up feeling bloated uh retaining fluid
and feeling really irritable in the head
which made me crave certain things and
want to do that same thing the next day
I mean there was even a year I think I
had
a pint of Ben and Jerry's ice cream
right before a bed but if you're waking
up feeling nauseous headachy bloated
it's usually that and also uh stiffness
you wake up with stiffness it's usually
something you ate that's affecting your
liver and if you have a liver issue you
can create a lot of stiffness now a
couple key points to help you wake up
feeling refreshed is you must do
intermittent fasting okay and skip that
breakfast in fact this is what I would
do I would have your first meal at noon
and your second meal at least five hours
before you go to bed okay I mean even
earlier if you could you will find a
huge Improvement in your sleep cycles if
you don't eat so close to when you go to
bed I mean you should just prove this to
yourself okay
one day you eat right before you go to
bed next day you eat like at five okay
or maybe even at four in the afternoon
and nothing after that watch how well
you sleep one of the things that people
have temptations they have certain
Cravings they have certain habits and
they're constantly giving in to them the
way that you strengthen your willpower
is just by
avoiding these things okay and it takes
a while but as soon as you start doing
it you'll get momentum but to constantly
give in to the body and just cave just
weakens your your willpower over time
and don't ever ask your body hmm what is
my body in the mood for because it's not
going to give you the right answer the
attitude that I use with my body is
basically
um I'm going to give you the food that
you need to survive and get healthy and
I see that my stomach is grumbling but
I'm not going to give into that I will
feed you when I'm good and ready I have
to constantly remind my body who is boss
I mean it's literally crazy what's
happening with people out of control
with food I mean completely
um out of control I mean they're just
letting their bodies dictate exactly
what they want at any given moment so
it's a trap you got to get out of the
Trap and you have to start putting in
control over your body and when you
start doing intermittent fasting boy
your hunger goes right away a couple
other things now related to this fatigue
in the morning it's if you're sitting in
front of a computer like I am um a good
portion of the day or you're staring at
your cell phone or a laptop whatever
you're gonna get a couple things happen
you're going to get EMF electromagnetic
fields that are going to affect your
body and I bought this little tri-filled
device to detect em MF and I found the
back wall where my bed is had a lot of
problems and extended this
electromagnetic field like eight feet
out from the wall and so I was sleeping
in the bathing in this electromagnetic
field and I literally had an electrician
take the wall down and um fix some of
the cross wires and boy did I sleep good
after that so you have that and then you
have this blue light that does not help
your eyes and then you also have the
cell phone connected to your head I mean
that is not good for your brain you talk
about brain fog and then you also have
these things right here which I hate
with a passion but unfortunately
I have to use them when I'm reading
certain things but the problem is when I
use them it makes things worse so I
literally have to take half the day and
take them off and just go for a walk and
just look at things in the distance to
actually correct some of that but you
know you might think that you're tired
but it could be just the glasses that
are making your eyes tired making your
head tired as far as exercise goes very
very important to use exercise to flush
out adrenaline and stress and cortisol
through the day it's going to help
increase your tolerance for stress it's
going to help you sleep deeper
especially if you do like three times a
week high intensity interval training
that can greatly help your sleep as well
as long walks or hikes or even better
yet doing physical work around your
house outside somewhere very therapeutic
to your sleep and the quality of waking
up feeling good also jet lag if you want
to handle your jet leg it's a real
simple solution
if you fly somewhere take about 30 or 40
000 units of vitamin D okay and that
pretty much resets the clock in your
brain temperature is another important
thing when you're sleeping uh it's best
if you're on the cooler side that will
help the quality of sleep and make you
wake up feeling better your mattress did
you realize you spend
one third of your entire life on a
mattress so invest in a good mattress
and keeping the window open if at all
possible will greatly help
your ability to sleep and lastly make
sure that you're breathing through your
nose when you're sleeping
I created a very interesting video on
that I'm going to put that up right here
you should watch that video next